this episode is brought to you by tonal
t-o-n-a-l
get ready for the smartest home gym
you've ever seen that's a men's health
headline about tonal folks and that
gives you the gist
if you're wondering about the smart part
tonal's homepage also features a quote
from the new york times
quote the machine knew my strength
better than i did
end quote more on that in just a minute
by eliminating traditional metal weights
tonal can deliver 200 pounds of
resistance in a device smaller than a
flat screen tv
total mounts on your wall with no floor
space required
i've had a tonal unit now for six to 12
months
which i got after a number of very close
friends recommended tonal
and it allows me to do things i would
normally need a much
larger gym for like cable chop and lift
or rotational exercises things i wrote
about
in the four hour body and it allows me
to do these things that are nearly
impossible otherwise like eccentric
loading which i'll mention later
tonal is precision engineered and
designed to be the world's most advanced
strength studio and personal trainer
it uses breakthrough technology like
adaptive digital weights and ai learning
together with the best experts in
resistance training so you get stronger
faster so what are these adaptive
digital weights tonal's patented digital
weight system
makes thousands of calculations a second
to deliver you a smooth weightlifting
experience
using advanced electronic motor
technology total lets you adjust the
weight in one pound increments
something that was never possible with
traditional dumbbells it's easy to dial
weights up and down with the touch of a
button
right in the grip itself it's pretty
cool tonal also has
built-in dynamic weight modes like
chains eccentric that's
e-c-c-e-n-t-r-i-c and their
patent-pending smart flex technology
so you can experiment with more ways to
get stronger faster without the hassle
of extra equipment like chains
and bands and it once again fits on the
wall like flat screen
tv so you can make the best use out of
the smallest footprint
in your home or garage wherever you end
up putting it so
try tonal t-o-n-a-l the world's smartest
home gym for 30 days in your home and if
you don't love it
you can return it for a full refund
visit www.tonal.com that's t-o-n-a-l
and for a limited time get 100 off of
the smart accessories when you use promo
code
tim 100 at checkout that's www.tonal.com
promo code tim 100 tonal
be your strongest
this episode is brought to you by all
form if you've been listening to this
podcast for a while you've probably
heard me talk about helix
sleep and their mattresses which i've
been using since 2017. i have two of
them
upstairs from where i'm sitting at this
moment and now helix has gone beyond the
bedroom and started making
sofas they just launched a new company
called all form a-l-l-f-o-r-m and
they're making premium
customizable sofas and chairs shipped
right to your door at a fraction of the
cost of traditional stores
so i'm sitting in my living room right
now and it's entirely all form
furniture i've got two chairs i've got
an ottoman and i have an l sectional
couch and i'll come back to that you can
pick your fabric
they're all spill stain and scratch
resistant the sofa color
the color of the legs the sofa size the
shape to make sure it's perfect for you
and your home
also all form arrives in just three to
seven days and you can assemble it all
yourself in a few minutes no tools
needed i was quite astonished by how
modular
and easy these things fit together kind
of like lego pieces they've got arm
chairs love seats all the way up to an 8
seat
sectional so there's something for
everyone you can also start small and
kind of build on top of it if you want
to get a smaller couch and then build
out on it which is actually in a way
what i did because i can turn
my l-sectional couch into a normal
straight couch and then with a separate
ottoman
in a matter of about 60 seconds it's
pretty rad so i mentioned i have
all these different things in this room
i use the natural leg finish which is
their lightest color
and i dig it i mean i've been using
these things hours and hours and hours
every single day so i am using
what i am sharing with you guys and if
getting a sofa without trying it in
store sounds
risky you don't need to worry all form
sofas are delivered directly to your
home with fast free shipping
and you get 100 days to decide if you
want to keep it that's more than three
months and if you don't love it they'll
pick it up for free and give you a full
refund
your sofa frame also has a forever
warranty that's literally
forever so check it out take a look
they've got all sorts of cool stuff
to choose from i was skeptical and it
actually worked
it worked much better than i could have
imagined and i'm very very happy
so to find your perfect sofa check out
allform.com
tim that's a-l-l-f-o-r-m.com
tim all form is offering 20 off all
orders to you my dear listeners at
allform.com
tim make sure to use the code tim at
checkout
that's allforum.com tim and use code tim
at checkout at this altitude i can run
flat out for a half mile before my hands
start
shaking can i answer your personal
questions
[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show and i
want to skip
my long usual preamble because we are
going to run out of time before we run
out of material
with today's guest i've been looking
forward to this conversation for a long
time
many many years in fact dennis mckenna
you can find him on twitter at
dennismckenna4 and we'll
provide many other links dennis's
research is focused on the
interdisciplinary study of amazonian
ethnopharmacology he has conducted
extensive
ethno-botanical field work in the
peruvian amazon and we will define a lot
of terms in this episode so don't worry
about getting lost in the weights too
quickly
his doctoral research at the university
of british columbia
focused on the ethnopharmacology of
ayahuasca and ukuhei
and we'll double check the pronunciation
two tryptamine-based hallucinogens used
by indigenous peoples in the northwest
amazon
he is a founding board member of the
hefter research institute which does
exceptional work and was a key organizer
and participant in the
huasca project that's hoasca
project the first biomedical
investigation of ayahuasca
he is the younger brother of terence
mckenna from 2000 to 2017
he taught courses on ethnopharmacology
as well as plants and human affairs
at the center for spirituality and
healing at the university of minnesota
in 2019
in collaboration with colleagues he
incorporated a new non-profit the
mckenna academy of natural philosophy
which we will discuss
in the spring of 2019 he emigrated to
canada with his wife sheila and now
resides in
abbotsford british columbia you can find
him on all the socials
instagram at dennis mckenna twitter
dennis mckenna 4 facebook at
dennis john j-o-n mckenna and
also mckenna academy that's m c k e n n
a academy on facebook on instagram
and on twitter dennis welcome to the
show
thank you tim it's a pleasure to be here
i thought i would i would start
with a bit of history and pull in some
colorful characters while we're at it
could you please describe your first
meeting
with richard evan schulte's and that can
kind of segue into
who schulte's was but i really enjoyed
this story and in your book the
brotherhood of the screaming abyss which
we'll talk about i've
i printed out my amazon kindle
highlights i have 189 highlights from
that book we're not going to go through
them all
but let's start with your meeting with
schulte's
if you wouldn't mind schulte's was a
professor
of harvard he's been called the father
of ethnobotany he certainly was not
because ethnobotany as a discipline
existed before there was schulte's
but he was one of the more high-profile
people he was the director
of the botanical museum at harvard
university for many years
and he is he made many contributions to
amazonian botany but
the one he's most notorious for and most
well known for
is he was probably the world's expert on
what we used to call hallucinogenic
plants
psychedelic plants used in different
parts of the world but that was what
made him so
famous and like many people i
envisioned a career in ethnopharmacology
for myself
which is something that i sort of
realized was possible
when i was 18. we can go back to this
this is earlier than schulte's
but i got my hands on this amazing book
called the ethnopharmacologic search
for psychoactive drugs but i digress
we can return to that so schulte's was a
figure
of just a towering figure in this field
like einstein and physics or
of that stature and many many people
with a passion about psychedelic plants
and indigenous
use of these things you know looked up
to schulte's and
wanted to work with him and i was one of
those
and in 1974 i was living in berkeley
with my brother or close by my brother
who was
living there and i determined to
go see the great man you know to make a
pilgrimage essentially
to schulte's and in those days there was
a deal
you could buy a bus ticket 60 dollars
for 60 days and you could get as far as
you could go
as long as you kept it within 60 days so
i
made this pilgrimage to harvard to
cambridge
and where was your starting point well i
started at berkeley
and i went first down to louisiana
hammond louisiana and visited some
friends of mine
who owned a leather shop a hippie
leather
shop a wonderful bunch of people running
a leather shop
in this totally redneck town why did i
go see them well i went to see them
because they lived
out in the country where there were
pastures and cattle
i went there basically to hunt for
mushrooms and
you know and my idea in my
this is 1974 and my idea was well
you know i'll get a bunch of mushrooms
and
dry them take them back to california
and sell them well
it was like the worst season for
mushrooms in like
five years that they'd live there so
i went down there and i did find some
mushrooms but just a few
plenty for my own needs but i didn't
have grocery bags of them or anything
like that
that was the first place i went was
hammond louisiana and then i just
got on the old bus and continued on
i stopped and saw interestingly this
anthropologist
in maryland who had studied the yanomami
one of the amazonian tribes that uses
these psychedelic snuffs and he was a
linguist he was probably
one of the few people in the world that
actually spoke
you know mommy he had some interesting
samples that he collected
i went there basically to pick up those
samples and hang on with him
and then i continued up to boston and i
had an
old girlfriend who happened to live in
boston so
uh and we were still on good terms so so
i went there i had a place to stay
and then i went i mean i i saw
schulte's before i saw the girlfriend i
basically got off the bus
and went immediately to the botanical
museum
it was an incredible experience for me
because i was like in total awe
of this man i mean it was like it was
like an audience with the pope or
something
you know but he wasn't pope-like at all
he was just
a very kindly down-to-earth ordinary
person
and he welcomed me and took me to lunch
at the harvard faculty club
and and we talked about what i
could work on and what would you like to
do was the way the conversation started
out
so because terence and i had
been to colombia in 1971 and one of the
things we were looking for was this ukuh
this
orally active varola preparation which
eventually ended up being one of the
foci of my
doctoral work but that was 10 years in
the future
but i was interested in varola i was
interested in those snuffs and he's well
you could go to
the amazon and study varola and
sort out the chemistry of it so he said
that would be a possibility i'd
totally you know appreciate that endorse
that
he said well there are two things you
need to do before you do that
and i had my degree i got my
undergraduate degree in 1973
but he said you need more chemistry and
you need to take more organic chemistry
and you need to take more
taxonomy you know what you know as plant
classification the classic
approach to plant classification so
i said yes sir absolutely and
you know i got the message i got back on
the bus i went back to berkeley
and i moved back to colorado where i'm
from
even though i had my bachelor's degree i
just enrolled in a couple of
courses advanced organic chemistry and
the taxonomy specialty i chose to look
in was grass systematics
which was like torture
systematic classification is the most
arcane
difficult thing you could do i must have
had something about wanting to punish
myself
but i studied grass systematics and
organic chemistry
and an interesting unexpected delight in
this
was the the person that was the
chemistry teacher
of this organic chemistry course a man
named frank stermitz
turns out he was quite a well-known
alkaloid chemist he used to illustrate
his lectures with
well so here's lsd here's how you make
lsd here's how the fungus makes lsd
and he was a brilliant guy and another
mentor
and he was said well don't go work for
schulte's go work for
norman farnsworth chicago and i said no
no you don't understand schulte's is
gone
and socialities encouraged me to apply
and i was getting these courses that he
thought i really needed to have on my
transcripts and i applied and i didn't
get in
you know i did not get accepted into
harvard which was
kind of a crushing blow but not
unexpected
it was a blessing in disguise in some
ways because
while all this was going on i was living
in
fort collins colorado going to colorado
state
my friend larry beasley was an old
friend from high school
and he was a horticulturalist and as it
turned out he was running the greenhouse
at colorado state university when i
moved there
so i had access to the greenhouse
and brought in some ayahuasca cuttings
that we had from california
and also i had access to a sterile
culture lab they were doing tissue
culture there
which can also be adapted to doing
fungal culture
and i was messing around with ways to
try to figure out how to grow the
philosophy cubensis and i had
access to a university lab to do this
work in
which was amazing and we tried a few
things and
actually succeeded in growing mushrooms
out of these
mason jars on sterilized substrates
you're probably familiar with the book
psilocybin magic mushroom growers guide
which
i published under pseudoman one of your
great
contributions to humankind maybe the
most significant contribution
but that was the method that we
developed there and in the process of
growing the mushrooms and then sampling
the mushrooms and
and just getting excited about being
able to grow mushrooms i thought wow
well maybe i'll change my
focus from varroa to psilocybin
mushrooms
and i wrote to schulte's about this and
i said what would you
think of that and he wrote back a rather
kind of stuffy letter you know
saying well i my specialty is higher
plants
and i think if you want to work on fungi
you should talk to dr
alexander h smith at the university of
michigan
but basically saying i mean the subtext
was you're a traitor dare you
yeah not really i mean he was something
there was subsequent
encounters but he he basically said if
you want to study
amazonian plants i'm all in i'd i'd be
happy to have you
and as it turned out i didn't get
accepted so that opportunity was taken
away
but the unexpected benefit of this was
that
some years later well this was 74
so after that i
did my master's at the university of
hawaii
not studying psychoactive plants my plot
to study psychoactive plants there was
undermined
but i ended up applying to the
university of british columbia and i
started there
in 1979 and my supervisor there
was a man named neil towers also
kind of a giant in this field not as
gigantic
as schulte's but very much known in the
world of phytochemistry and
ethnobotany and so on and he was quite
open to me working on
mushrooms i actually started out in his
program
because he had come to hawaii
while i was a graduate student there and
my supervisor in hawaii was
another one of these incredible mentors
that
i've been blessed with throughout my
academic career sandy siegel and dr
siegel
whenever anybody came to visit a
visiting professor or
dignitary he would always invite the
graduate students up to his house
we'd sit around and have pizza and beer
and shoot the breeze with the whatever
luminary was in town and
dr towers was one of the luminaries
in the process of having this
conversation he said well i've got this
uh
young masters student working on the
philosophy it's working on the
enzyme that converts psilocybin to
silicon
phosphatase and she's not getting very
far with it but it's a very interesting
project and wish there was somebody to
kind of continue
that work you know and i practically
spit my beer out and i said
well dr i've had some interest in this
and what do you think about letting me
do it and
you know what do you think about taking
me on and i said well yeah if you're
interested
that's a possibility so we started
corresponding
and i was like midway through my
master's thesis in hawaii at that point
and we started corresponding and i got
accepted
and i got with dr tower's support i
actually got a four-year
graduate fellowship and i started
working on philosophy
and the idea and i had developed the
technique for growing them
dennis may i pause for just one second
certainly i'm
getting off of many tangents oh no i
love all the tangents that is actually
kind of the if there's any theme to this
show it is it is embracing tangents but
i want to
just mention a few things and ask a
couple of questions but i want you to
bookmark that so we're
sure we're in canada or headed to canada
at that point but i just want to
mention a few things so is it true
that when you first met schulte's
when you walked in he was effectively
hugging an
air conditioner and the reason i ask is
that if you look at
photographs of schulte's in his prime it
very much evokes
an indiana jones minus the tomb raiding
of course
resilience and durability i mean you see
him in native dress you see him
right really fully engaged as uh not
just an observer but as a participant
he spent more than a decade as i
understand it so
scouting 15 years 15 years in the amazon
and this is not flying first class
no to the amazon
so your first exposure to him was him
hugging an
air conditioner as i understand it yeah
well he was
obviously a little past his prime at
that point but
when i took this bus and got off the bus
it was like a
early september it was a sweltering
summer
and i got off the bus and i took my
backpack i must have looked a mess i
mean i'd been
literally on the bus for four days you
know
but i got to his office and i went to
the desk downstairs i said i'm here to
see dr
schulte's they said oh he's upstairs in
his office
so i went upstairs and couldn't see
anybody there there was nobody at the
reception desk and i sort of
peered in this dark room with all the
blinds
and wiping the sweat from my brow i mean
and i could see him back in the back of
this office
laboratory that he had there and he was
hugging the air conditioner know when
you have an ac you matter if you might
as well use it i suppose
well yeah i figured and i i mean it was
like utterly charming you know
because i expected this swashbuckling
like you say indiana jones you know
tough
guy and he was all those things but
you got an air conditioner you may as
well hug him
that's what he did yeah it was very
disarming
i love it i absolutely love it let me
let me also pick up on a couple of other
points and ask
just a couple of definitions for people
listening which we'll get to in a minute
but i would like to read a few things
from the brotherhood of the screaming
abyss if you're willing to bear with me
because
i think it will hopefully help tie some
things together
in the minds of those who are not
familiar with your background and your
work
so sanford siegel who you mentioned so
his research interests among many other
things included exobiology
but i want to read just a paragraph
about him
from your book and then three sections
that i pulled out about
science it's going to take me a minute
but if you could bear with me okay
so this is from the book and on stanford
siegel this is where the excerpt begins
quote
in his nasa funded work he was extremely
creative in his thinking about stress
physiology and extreme environments for
example he wondered what would happen if
he tried to grow a cactus underwater
turns out it grows fine as long as you
bubble oxygen and carbon dioxide through
the water
how well does a tarantula survive under
a radiation flux similar to that at a
martian surface it survives just fine
for months
can you germinate onion seedlings and
liquid ammonia as a substitute for water
yes
money can substitute for water in many
biological processes
he had a genius for thinking of these
incredibly creative exciting and simple
experiments
and yet they all had a rationale and a
reason behind them he was an out of the
box
thinker and then i'm going to jump to
what you said
separately in the book about science
quote i knew scientific thought had its
limits but before we could reject
science the most powerful set of
intellectual tools ever developed by the
human mind we first had to learn how to
do science
then if we still wanted to reject it we
could do so as scientists with full
knowledge of
what it was we were rejecting
i think these these are really really
important to tie together because
you have such broad exposure and as i
understand it there were many influences
early on
two of which were i believe it was the
yaki way of knowledge by carlos
castaneda even though subsequently a lot
of people and you're aware of this
came to conclude that a lot of that if
not most of it was fictionalized and
a book that i have about 20 feet from
here which is the first edition
of something you already mentioned the
ethnopharmacologic
search for psychoactive drugs espd
and that was from 1967 i have the
updated
i shouldn't say updated but a second
volume from 2017
which you organized which was the 50th
anniversary
could you speak to perhaps the
the appeal of science because what i've
noticed in the
let's call it the psychedelic ecosystem
is that you
have purists in many different silos
if that makes sense and part of the
reason i i've been so excited to
spend time with you is because you have
been a boundary walker
of sorts across these different silos
what is it that drew you most
to science and the scientific method
in addition to some of the facets
perhaps represented by castaneda's work
in some respect
i think the 1967 1968 were
like pivotal years for me in terms of my
discovery of my
professional direction and my
professional interests
as well as being psychedelics these are
also
very personal things but that year
1968 is the year that these two books
came across my desk the teachings of don
juan the first edition
that my brother gave me for my 18th
birthday
and then the ethnopharmacologic search
for psychoactive drugs which i
am not even sure i don't even remember
where
i originally got the first edition but
that had come across
my radar a few months earlier
and these two books were very important
for me in terms of
framing my interests it made me aware
that there was this ethnographic
background of these traditional
backgrounds even though
we probably most people agree that
castaneda made a lot of this stuff up
didn't really matter it doesn't really
matter it made it clear
that there was a body of traditional
knowledge around the use of these
things whether what he described was
accurate or not
didn't matter that was one page one side
of the frame
and then the ethnopharmacologic search
for psychoactive drugs
made me aware that a lot of this was
about chemistry
and plants and pharmacology and
molecules
and and you know a more hard science
biologically oriented aspect to it so
these two things
seem to fit together very well and i
thought
ethnopharmacology is a real thing you
know at least to the extent that
this book exists it's a real thing and
could you define
ethnopharmacology ethnopharmacology
there's
various definitions of it the one i like
is kind of tortured it's kind of long
but i'll explain
why i like it so ethnopharmacology is
the interdisciplinary
by definition interdisciplinary
scientific investigation
of biologically active substances used
or observed
by humans in traditional societies
and the reason it's so tortured is it's
not always about plants it's not always
about medicinal plants
it's not always about things that humans
ingest
for example arrow poisons totally
legitimate kind of subject for
ethnopharmacology and then traditional
societies kind of limits the scope we're
talking about
not i mean in some sense all of
pharmacology is ethnopharmacology
because it's people
doing it you know but we're talking
about
traditional knowledge indigenous
knowledge and that sort of thing
that's the formal definition of
ethnopharmacology that i like
and i think it's also worth highlighting
for folks and you would have
i'm sure dozens or hundreds of examples
how many
commonly used compounds or drugs
have come out of in some form
ethnopharmacology whether it be aspirin
or you mentioned
dark poisons that you know curare
leading then
into anesthesia
and the list just goes on and on and on
there's so many things we take for
granted
right that have their origins in these
places the whole spectrum
really of when you're talking about
natural products
especially for things like
cms active natural products and so on
they come out of a cultural context we
know about these things because
they have a cultural context and if you
look at
even just herbal medicines herbal
remedies
every one of these things that you can
buy in the in the drugstore or the
health food store
has a story behind it has a cultural
backstory
and then entrepreneurial forces and
commercial forces take
that and develop products out of it for
example kavakava
is a good example of that i mean it's
now a supplement and you can buy it in
health food store
it's a very useful muscle relaxant and
sort of tranquilizer but it comes out of
the context
of polynesia and traditional medicine
many many things are that way so
there's always a cultural backstory
that's what i like about
ethnopharmacology it ties those kinds of
things together with the
nuts and bolts side of it what are the
active ingredients what's the chemistry
what's the pharmacology so on if you
don't mind i know this is a bit
stochastic but i would love to jump
into this volume
the 50th anniversary volume of the
ethnopharmacologic search for
psychological
drugs and just as background and please
correct me if i get any of this wrong
but the
the 1967 gathering was subsidized by the
us government i think it was the was it
the nimh
nimh that's right national institute of
mental health
and so you had this gathering of titans
of sorts
to discuss exactly as the title would
imply the ethnopharmacologic search for
psychoactive drugs
after which a volume was produced
printed and sold by the us government
which included
the findings and suffice to say shortly
thereafter
you have the nixon administration the
controlled substances act and
game over and then you organized this
50th anniversary
and just to give people an idea of the
contents and also
i want to tell people if you are
interested in the science
this is published by synergetic press
you can find it on the synergetic press
website as well as on amazon
this is a beautifully produced double
volume where you have the original
1967 and then the 2017 edition
the contents are just fascinating
and one of them that i'd love to dig
into and doesn't necessarily have to
our discussion doesn't have to be
reflective exclusively of the content in
this
broad spectrum roles of harmine in
ayahuasca by dale millard
could you speak to some of the more
recent
findings related to ayahuasca which
could include this discussion of harming
but
i think a lot of folks have assumed that
ayahuasca as this psychedelic brew
principally containing
banisteriups is a copy of this vine and
a plant source containing dmt like
choprunna
or other psychotropis that the
divine really just serves to render the
dmt orally
absorbable or active but it seems like
there's a lot more
to the story it does do that it
it does do that it's the mao inhibitor
monoamine oxidase inhibitor
that renders the the dmt containing that
mixture plants acting
because dmt itself as you know is not
orally active
if you just take it pure or if you make
a tea
of chakruna one of these and then drink
it by itself
nothing's going to happen unless you
have an ml inhibitor on board
but it turns out the alkaloids of
banisteriopsis these
beta-carbolines are much more than just
mao inhibitors
for example one of the primary alkaloids
in ayahuasca
is harmine and harmine is a strong mao
inhibitor but it also stimulates
neurogenesis which is nerve growth
and these are recent findings another
constituent in
ayahuasca is a related alkaloid called
tetrahydroharmine which is
an mao inhibitor but also a serotonin
reuptake inhibitor so it has like ssri
type activity and also
some other unexpected things for one
thing and this was
came out of our wasca study in brazil
it has long-term effects on the
levels of the serotonin transporters in
the brain that the serotonin
transporters are the
pre-synaptic molecules that take
serotonin back up
out of the synapse and recycles
and re-releases it well like ssris
tetrahydroharmine inhibits that but it
also
causes a long-term elevation in the
levels of these serotonin transporters
and that was a unique finding we didn't
know what to expect but that came out of
the study
and it was kind of surprising but then
when we
found this effect you know this is all
done this is all in vitro we took
tissue samples platelet samples and so
on and this was all done in the lab but
we found this
persistent elevating effect on the
serotonin transporters we thought
what does that be wasn't really clear we
were asking a
naive question is there anything
biochemical that makes regular ayahuasca
drinkers different biochemically than
normal people or other people and this
was one clear difference
we didn't really know what it meant but
then we looked into the literature and
we found out
there were a number of pathologies that
were associated with abnormal
deficits in the serotonin transporters
for example various kinds of alcoholism
addiction suicidality even homicidal
behavior various kinds of
behavioral which happen to be
the very pathologies that many of the
people in our udv
studied were saying ayahuasca had saved
them
usually from alcoholism that was usually
their problem
and if they stayed in the church
in the supportive context and drank
ayahuasca regularly
then they stayed on track and many they
were on track these were
very behaviorally psychologically
functional people
not sick if they were sick they were
cured and they attributed it to
ayahuasca
and then in our in vitro studies in a
couple of
vile assays we found that it was really
tetrahydroharmony
that was having this effect and the
course of action
was over about two weeks and my friend
jace callaway who was one of the
investigators on this and figured out
how to do it
he had access to brain imaging
technology
at his laboratory in finland he was a
doing postdocs in in finland
so he tried taking tetrahydroharmine
himself
and imaging himself and show well sure
enough it
did raise the levels of these serotonin
transporters
on about a two-week cycle and then if
you stop taking it
it went back down to baseline so does
that mean on the two-week cycle that
after one administration
the levels remained elevated for two
weeks or that it required two weeks of
administration to elevate
it required about two weeks of
continuous administration
to bring it to that level and that's
kind of that was the cycle that the udv
customarily they took it every couple of
weeks
not that they knew about this effect but
that was just their practice you know i
guess they knew about
in a sense they indirectly knew about
the effect but not the mechanism
right that's right and that's right
and for for people who don't know udv
i'm probably going to mispronounce it
but that's the
vegetal something like that one of the
syncretic churches
found in brazil yeah i should have
explained that one of the syncretic
churches
the group that invited us in to
do this biomedical study in the early
90s
that was one of the chief findings
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront did you know
if you missed 10 of the best performing
days after the 2008 crisis you would
have missed out on 50 percent
five zero percent of your returns don't
miss out on the best days in the market
stay invested in a long-term automated
investment portfolio wealthfront
pioneered the automated investing
movement sometimes referred to as
robo-advising
and they currently oversee 20 billion
dollars of assets for their clients
wealthfront can help you diversify your
portfolio minimize fees
and lower your taxes takes about three
minutes to sign up and then wealthfront
will build you a globally diversified
portfolio of etfs based on your risk
appetite and manage it for you at an
incredibly low cost
wealthfront software constantly monitors
your portfolio day in and day out so you
don't have to
they look for opportunities to rebalance
and tax loss harvest to lower the amount
of taxes you pay
on your investment gains their newest
service is called autopilot
and it can monitor any checking account
for excess cash to move into savings or
an investment account
they've really thought of a ton they've
checked a lot of boxes
smart investing should not feel like a
roller coaster ride let the
professionals do the work for you
go to wealthfront.com tim and open a
wealthfront investment account today
and you'll get your first five thousand
dollars managed for free for life that's
wealthfront.comtim
wealthfront will automate your
investments for the long term and you
can get started today at wealthfront.com
tim
does the udv differentiate between
different types of brews for different
purposes my understanding is that these
some of the dimensions or some of the
members
or perhaps groups within santo daimi
another one of these syncretic churches
do have different
i don't want to say admixtures but
concentrations of different things in
different brews for different purposes
are you aware of that existing in within
the udv
yes yes the udv does
have that they do have different
formulations
and so on and they don't talk about them
i mean
we were not able to get any information
out of them about that other than the
fact that yes we do have
these different formulations i mean we
came up against
a couple of interesting things about
when we were dealing with the udv
which was that they were very concerned
that
ayahuasca or iwasca as they called it be
viewed
as a sacrament not as a medicine
you know and so if you watch this as a
drug right that'd be a big
much less a drug they didn't like the
idea that you would study it as a drug
they were totally open to doing this
biomedical study
but as far as going the next step and
looking into mechanisms and that sort of
thing
they were kind of conflicted about that
they could see the value of it but then
they didn't like the idea of
godless science delving into their
central mystery sacrament you know and
i could understand that but as a result
of that we
we lost some opportunities to do some
interesting things
totally i wonder if that would be
different now because my
understanding i think i got this from
the book is that
or maybe it was from different reading
that i did
of yours that part of the reason for
their cooperation was politically sort
of
legally motivated in the sense they
wanted the
local slash national government and
potential policy makers to view this as
beneficial
and so they were open to showing the
benefits
but they didn't want reductionist
science to
as you put it remove the mystery by
explaining some secular mechanism of
action
yeah there was definitely a political
aspect to this that
this is a big reason why they wanted
this work to be done
by outside investigators who
presumably would you know if it was just
udv
and there were scientists in the in the
udv it was a
middle to upper class demographic
segments but they wanted people from the
outside to be the chief
investigators to avoid the perception
that the work would be biased and that's
one reason i got
invited and charlie grove was the chief
principal investigator i invited him to
do that and
he became that so they wanted this
regulatory agency called confin
kind of a combination of the dea and the
fda they wanted to
present data to khan fans that showed
that
this was not a public health
menace or danger and also that it was
beneficial
or potentially beneficial so there was
definitely a
political sub agenda here but
as it turned out i mean we just did the
science and the science
supported that it was beneficial
almost all of our subjects had joined
the udv
in a state of life crisis and they felt
like the medicine the tea
as they called it and the very
supportive context of the udv
they said that's equally necessary but
they felt like that was a vessel for
redemption essentially and turning their
lives around
and it's a complex thing it's a
complicated matter
i'm endlessly fascinated by the uh the
syncretic
churches that use ayahuasca as a
sacrament as i think there's so much
that could be learned when you have
these relatively large groups consuming
twice per month
i mean it's just an incredible
opportunity question for you around
iowa because i think in the
already alluded to this but in the minds
of some ayahuasca is one thing
right it's like a it's like an old
fashioned that is always made the same
way
but there are many different
cocktails that could be called ayahuasca
in
the brotherhood of the screaming abyss
you talked very briefly
about and i'm not sure if you called
this in the book but chagro panga which
is
also i think it's a diplomat terrorist
cabrera is that how that's pronounced
mm-hmm
[Laughter]
did you ever have the opportunity to
consume ayahuasca with
the pongo yes yes yeah
experientially did you find it to be
different well i only consumed it a few
times i found it to be
a shorter acting and you know in terms
of the visionary
stage of the experience and also more
intense
so there's something pharmacokinetically
going on there with the absorption of it
but people are mistaken if they think
ayahuasca is one
thing ayahuasca is a very complex
in the cultural context it's a very
complex thing there are many varieties
of ayahuasca
the vine there are then all these
admixture plants some of which
contain dmt and varieties of those
and then a whole pharmacopoeia of other
admixture plants that are
more or less associated with ayahuasca
they're part of the
dietis which is a common practice in the
amazon you learn
about the properties of other medicinal
plants by
taking them and then you take ayahuasca
either
in combination or after you take them
and you learn about their properties
from the visions that i want to give you
about there
so ayahuasca is like the pipeline to
plant wisdom
in a certain way to tap into this
i don't know what you might call it guy
in mind that's represented by
these many admixture plants so there's a
whole lot of
work left to be done with ayahuasca
and looking into more depth than
we were able to look at at that time
that's one of the
projects that we're trying to get off
the ground with the mckenna academy we
want to do a
very extensive phytochemical and
ethnobotanical survey of
of different ayahuasca brews document
their preparation
document the plants that go into them
and then
follow that up with bioassays and and
just
get a better handle on the varieties of
these different gurus and their uses
why would we care why do we want to do
this well it's gathering
knowledge it's gathering information but
the potential
practical outcome of this is that you
can formulate
brews that might be specific for
different types of disorders you know
maybe some work better for addiction
some work better for trauma some work
better for
depression or that sort of thing all of
this is
kind of supported by the fork knowledge
but there's been nothing like a
controlled study of any of this it's
very hard to get
funding to study ayahuasca in a clinical
setting because it's
not a pure compound it doesn't lend
itself to the same kind of
double-blind placebo-controlled
protocols that you can
use with something like psilocybin
it's complicated it's very very
very seems very complex i'd love to ask
you about one
particular plant which well it's hard to
tell them apart sometimes because it
depends on the
the orientation uh you know it could be
da twitter
metal or could be brokemansi i want to
ask you about brugmansia
also called floripundi or toy do you
think there's a place
for that it scares the hell out of me
and i know it's
sometimes used but what is your
position if any on on bergman
well first of all you're right to be
scared
you know this is a very dangerous plant
it is not only toxic but it produces a
kind of delirium it's not a psychedelic
i sometimes say in my lectures it's a
true hallucinogen
but not psychedelic by that i mean
psychedelics you see hallucinations
sometimes behind the eyes or whatever
you usually
know that these things are
hallucinations with
romancia which used to be called the
genus is very close to detour in fact
they used to be
classified as detours but deterra the
experiences that you have
you see hallucinations and you cannot
tell
if they're real or not and so it
in that sense it's a true hallucination
but it's not psychedelic
and it is it's produces a state of
profound disorientation and
delirium essentially so it's used
very badly it's used as a date rape drug
and things like that
in brazil and colombia and it's often
associated with bruja
in the ayahuasca tradition in other
words
black magic sorcery and if you
take a brew of ayahuasca that contains
detura
or brigbanzia you can tell
because it causes this dry mouth
sensation which is typical of these
anticholinergics like
like tutura is that the like this
copolymine
exactly it's it's copolymer so you can
tell
and if you're taking ayahuasca that's
got to a
is the traditional word for for these
things
to a t-o-e accent
that's a good sign that you're dealing
with a brujo and that's a good sign that
you should get the hell out of there
you know because they do not have your
best interests at heart
and or unlikely to that said that you
have to acknowledge that
it has a place in in this whole
ayahuasca complex and
there may be people that can
practitioners that can use it
beneficially
but my own experiences with detura which
you've probably read about in the book
yeah you know that scared me away i mean
horrifying
no idea what i was getting into and i
was
we were very lucky we could have killed
ourselves
yeah there are documented lots of
documented fatalities
with both of those yeah and i think it's
you know i wanted to mention to bring
that up just because
there are risks associated with a lot of
these things
yeah documented fatalities with tobacco
over ingestion tobacco juice in the
amazon uh
you have to be really really careful
and you know i want to come back to a
second to this kind of hired
gun aspect i think as you put it in the
book
in the world of vegetarianism
and in this let's just call it the
medicine world in south america it's
not the case that everyone is focused
it's actually rarely the case that
practitioners are exclusively focused
on how we perhaps view these
medicines in north america for healing
for the
contending with and processing of trauma
the cosmic vision and the use case is
much much
broader and i just want to mention one
more thing which is even if you don't
believe
in black magic or anything like that you
can believe in manipulation
and the bregmancia like you mentioned in
colombia as one example and elsewhere
although i think that
people are kind of hip to this and law
enforcement is hip to it so perhaps they
use this decline but it's very common
that crime syndicates would take the
brugmansia
extract or somehow purify the
scopolamine
then they would have prostitutes or
other people
below the powder into the faces of
victims and this is this is the crazy
part i just that i want to highlight for
folks
that after which sometimes these victims
would be brought to their own home they
would
help the perpetrators load everything in
their house into a loading van
and they would appear totally normal to
say the doorman and so on
and 12 hours later have no recollection
of what they did
i mean it's it's wild i mean it brings
up kind of these visions of the serpent
and the rainbow like these are
it's it's it's crazy to think about it
it is they appear totally normal except
that they're helping
load all the furniture into the elevator
at three in the morning
you know yeah yeah i think it was
vice.com that vice did a good a good
piece on this he did a good
thing yeah so so that's the thing the
the detoura the bregmanzia confuses you
and makes you extremely suggestible so
you get
this stuff inside you and then people
say well let's go to your apartment
and take out all the furniture let's go
to your atm
and take out all your money and you say
oh well that sounds like a good idea
let's go do that
so black magic aside it can definitely
doesn't have to be magic it just puts
you in such a state of confusion
susceptibility suggestibility
that's the way it works it really is
so fascinating and simultaneously
sometimes terrifying to go
really deep into the rabbit hole with
this could you speak to
traditional use of plant medicine in
ayahuasca and i'm
hearkening back to the mention of the
sort of non-inherent good nature of
practitioners
or i always get was in the
non-inherently bad nature
sort of this neutral available for
higher aspect
in some instances that i think a lot of
people are not aware of could you sort
of speak
to to that a bit there are
rujos there are people who don't really
have your best interests at heart
and there are other people other
practitioners who
really are amazing healers and they can
help
a great deal of people but the thing is
that
the context of traditional use has
changed due to outside cultural
influences because like anything else
the people want to give the extra
heroes the ayahuasca tourists or
whatever they want to give their monies
worth
and so the nature of the ceremonies
changes
has changed in response to this i mean
back in the day before there was
anything like
when ayahuasca usage was still kind of a
tribal based tradition there wasn't all
this
outside influence it was the shaman who
took ayahuasca
not the people rarely would the
ayahuasca be given to
a person that came to the ceremony
unless there was
some specific illness or something they
wanted specifically to be treated
but it was the ios garrow who had the
visions
that downloaded the information
about the plants and other kinds of
practices they might
engage in to help people with healing
well that's all
changed the outside influence of
the global culture people are not going
to go to south america and spend all
this money
to sit and watch somebody take iowa
they are there to have the experience
and that's okay
i think it's just fascinating what
we're seeing go on now with the
ayahuasca tourism thing
it's definitely a complex thing it's not
necessarily
a completely bad thing or a completely
good thing it's
it's a mixed bag because many people are
helped
by this and all the tourists coming down
they bring
economic benefits to these communities
but then those are not
equitably distributed in a situation
where the local iowa
who used to be just some guy or some gal
that
was a person in the village who kind of
did this work
on the side and they had their own
livelihood farming
fishing or whatever well now these
people are kind of superstars and
they get a lot of income it generates a
lot of jealousy
within the community where that can
happen they also get priced out of the
local market
right they get a price exactly they get
priced out of the local market
there is uh pressure on
the resource base uh ayahuasca and
the admixture plants are being over
harvested
and there's not enough effort being made
to really
make sure the sources are sustainable
but that's changing the market is
adjusting to this
but these these changes take place over
they take years and there are some very
hopeful trends
now people are becoming more aware of
some of the issues with
over harvesting and so on let me pull
another
paragraph here and then i want to ask
you a question about some of your
personal
experiences and this is related to the
science
that was brought up earlier there are
many things in heaven and earth that are
beyond the ken of science and may remain
so forever anyone who has taken
psychedelics seriously or has had other
transcendent experiences is likely to
share that conclusion at the same time
science remains the most effective
method for asking questions of nature
and getting back
answers that can be tested and validated
so you you fascinate me on so many
different levels
i've actually read much more of your
writing than i have
read the writing of your brother and
part of the venn diagram
that makes you such a subjective
interest to me
is the the scientific let's call it the
esoteric and then the personal
and i've heard in other interviews you
talk about
when prompted you don't just volunteer
this but when people ask
about the number of sessions you have
done with let's say ayahuasca it seems
to number
even though you don't keep track in the
500 plus
i'd say strange something in that range
and
as far as i know you're not a member of
one of these syncretic
churches where people would drink twice
a month so people can do the math if
someone does that for decades it adds up
yeah i would love for you to speak to
because many people will hear that and
they'll say wait a second
you do it once it changes your life and
then you're kind of done why on earth
would you ever do it so many times
and i would just love to hear you speak
to that partly it's because of the
context in which
i have used ayahuasca and brought other
people to
south america to have these experiences
i've organized retreats and that sort of
thing
so i'm one of those i'm guilty if you
want to point at the
people that have fostered ayahuasca
tourism i've certainly contributed to
that
i'm a little conflicted about it so when
i do these retreats
then i drink people expect me to drink
and i do
drink the other reason is
i think every time you take it maybe
this is the more valid reason every time
that you take it or most times that you
take it
not every time you take ayahuasca it's
going to be a peak experience i mean
there's lots of times when it's
disappointing and you just get sick
and the brew is bad or whatever
but it has a lot to teach us there's a
lot to learn from
ayahuasca and even though you've taken
it multiple times you still
keep getting new insights or new i mean
the experience seems
worthwhile and so i keep taking it maybe
i'm thick skull
maybe maybe other people have an easier
way to assimilate the lesson and say
yeah i got the message okay
i don't need to do this anymore i've
come close to that a couple of times but
i think ron das was famously said
or maybe it was alan watts i'm not sure
who said once you get the message
hang up the phone right and i sort of
think i disagree with that i think
in other words the message is not the
same every time there is no standard
message
and this is a dynamic interaction
with with the plans that
you're learning from indigenous people
talk about plant teachers
and you can get into the weeds about
whether that's a valid concept are they
really intelligent are they not
the point is it doesn't really matter
whether the
plants the ayahuasca opens up
some part of yourself that
may present as something not the self
but that knows things
has information to transfer it doesn't
really matter what i say is the
information
good so every time you take it or when
you take it there's really a bottomless
well of things to still be thought about
and assimilated and so on so
i kind of don't believe in the hang up
the phone
approach my approach would be i guess
keep listening keep listening because
a lot of what you might hear will be
stuff that you've heard before but there
may be
new things that come along that make it
worth it
to stay engaged and so that's
how i relate to it it's not a waste of
time to keep listening and you've also
noted
that and they're you're not the only
person a luis eduardo luna and others
have also noted that these habitual
consumers
of ayahuasca often seem to remain
exceptionally sharp and lucid into older
age
and as i've thought about this and
spoken with
people who have a lot of experience like
yourself it seems like there are
kind of different frames through which
you can look at this experience
one is almost like the replacement of a
malfunctioning hip
so you have a hip replacement it's one
and done maybe you need it again 10
years later but that's
that's it that's the hang up the phone
approach and then there
there's this way of looking at it almost
like going to the gym
there are all these use cases
historically that seem to
at least offer other use cases like the
use of
ayahuasca for hunting let's just say
right
and you know another one that kind of
occurred to me as i talked to some of
these folks who drink
you know south america some some people
are drinking four or five
six times a week and it's almost like
you could let's say live in new york and
go to japan
and study things in japan in the hopes
that you can bring it back to new york
and apply it in your life
in new york but you could also go to
japan and just get to know japan
and the culture and how to operate in
that space
and i'd love to hear you speak to
outside of the
groups that you bring down where you are
expected to
drink how do you decide when to drink
well just usually the occasion presents
itself
it's rare that i would come to one of
these places and not
drink or just when it seems appropriate
is
when i decided if i'm in a situation
where
ayahuasca is being drunk then i would
probably drink it and i tend not to
go after it outside of a ceremonial
context and
even for a while i would say well i
don't even drink it
in the states or canada i just confine
it to
south america when i'm down there but
then i can't really stick to that
because there are opportunities here
now i go to a place called the saltera
in costa rica which is one of the higher
profile ayahuasca retreats i'm i'm an
advisor to saltera and i
i like the way they're doing it i think
they're very ethical about in their
approach to all this
and so it's a matter of opportunity
rather than anything else when it seems
appropriate but to your
what you alluded to before about how it
can be
in some ways ayahuasca and a lot of
psychedelics can be a big reset
but then there is the maintenance part
of it and
the work we did with the udv and the
finding about the modulation of these
serotonin transporters is really an
eye-opener because
what that speaks to is that regular use
of ayahuasca can
actually repair some of these deficits
in fact it may be the only drug or
medicine that can do that
i think peak experiences can be
major reset moments and i think this is
part of the
therapeutic profile of a lot of
psychedelics they
basically get you out of your default
mode network they get you out of your
personal reference frame they let you
look at situations from a slight remove
and you have insights as to your
existential situation whatever it might
be
not all psychedelic experiences not all
ayahuasca
experiences are necessarily these peak
experiences you know and they don't have
to be
they can be beneficial and they can help
you remember maybe as more accurate term
some of the insights you had from
previous experiences
and then i think there's a physiological
aspect too
particularly with ayahuasca like this
modulation
of the serotonin transporters and so on
and neurogenesis you mentioned that
a lot of practitioners ayahuasca seem to
be unusually sharp
and lucid even though they're maybe of
advanced age
and i think that is a reflection of
ayahuasca i think that
in general i am kind of a skeptic about
this whole micro dosing fad i have my
doubts about it but in the case of
ayahuasca i think
microdosing might make sense not for the
hallucinogenic psychedelic effects but
for the things
the beta-carbolines do for your nervous
system you think of them as kind of a
nerve tonic and keeping these serotonin
transporter levels elevated is probably
a very good thing
guarding against depression and that
kind of stuff so
again just like with the plants and the
chemistry there's
lots to be learned about the
pharmacology of ayahuasca too
so i want to talk about the mechanic
academy of natural floss we're going to
spend
a good amount of time on that before we
get there though since we're talking
about
some of the possible benefits of
in this case ayahuasca i want i would
love to discuss
perhaps the other side of the coin
and i know that the experiment at la
chorera does not
relate to ayahuasca specifically but i'd
like to
and i know you've described this many
many times we don't have to spend a ton
of air time on it but
the i'm gonna read a paragraph actually
two paragraphs
and then we can use that as a way of
backing into it if that's okay
here's the prelude to the chapter that
introduces the experiment at la chorera
which
again we don't have to spend too much
time on but just enough to kind of frame
this in some respects quote in some
respects everything in life before we
arrived at la chorrera was a prelude to
the events that engulfed us there
and everything afterwards has been a
reflection of them terence chronicled
the events
in true hallucinations though his
account may seem unlikely and bizarre i
believe it is largely accurate even if
interpretations vary as to what it all
meant
i can't vouch for every detail if only
because and this is the part that i'm
just going to highlight here
i was lost in hyperspace for much of the
time or overwhelmed by psychosis
again depending on interpretation anyone
with an interest in the
facts and quotation marks of our story
if the word even applies should regard
terence's narrative as required reading
and then we flash forward too much later
in the book
terence mentions that on march 20th we
all celebrated at one of bogota's finer
restaurants and that the others agreed i
was
totally back quote unquote they weren't
aware that in my mind i was in
telepathic communications with all the
waiters and that our dishes were being
wafted to the table by telekinesis
rather than alarm them i kept that to
myself
but except for a few episodes like that
i was doing all right
okay there's a lot to discuss here i
have
personally experienced many upsides to
psychedelic use including ayahuasca i've
also been
put into hyperspace as you put it on a
few occasions
or have become say destabilized
if you want to be a little less
charitable and i
have friends who have become
destabilized after diet does in some
cases
using ayahuasca in other cases in some
cases from lsd we don't have to go to
south america for this
for weeks months at a time and i would
love to just hear you
perhaps expand a little bit on your
personal experience
and if you have had more experiences
like this
so that people can be aware that this is
kind of one of the cards in the deck
it is one of the cards in the deck and
people should be
aware that this is a possibility
which is one reason why it's important
to have
a strong ritual environment a strong
ritual context
and a ios hero a practitioner that kind
of knows what
they're doing because they can keep you
on track
and get you out into hyperspace and get
you back
and that's kind of the whole essence of
shamanism
i have not since la torreira
had experiences that have kept me
three sheets to the wind if you will for
weeks at a time
it was not particularly pleasant and
you know i mean at the time i was i was
not concerned about getting back
all those concepts kind of evaporated
you know but after i did get back it
actually did get more restabilized
and truly back in my body and in
ordinary reality on reflection i
realized
what a dangerous place this was
to be in and that
potentially it could have gone the
opposite way where i never did
reintegrate
one of the reasons that i was able to
reintegrate i think was because
because of the circumstances of la
torreira
the process had to play out there were
people
in our group who said this is totally
out of control
we need to get these people out of here
into a psychiatric facility
and under treatment and terence and i
both completely resisted that because we
understood what was going on
at least we thought we did we were in
communication with each other it was
like
no you just need to let this play out
and and i think that was the right thing
i mean it was a you know i have a
a lecture idea of a talk i give it was a
psychotic break was a shamanic
initiation or was it an alien encounter
probably all three in a certain way but
it was closer to a shamanic
initiation than a certain not that i
call myself a shaman i'm not
but it's the shamanic initiation is
where you
get to explore these dimensions
and then you get back out you get back
onto your mundane feet in 3d
and ordinary reality and whatever that
is
i'm kind of wandering here but i i think
the point is because of the fact that
it was able to play itself out
from beginning to end it was actually a
very healing experiences
rather than being disorganized and
incoherent for the rest of my life maybe
some people say i
am but i don't think so
but it was actually a healing experience
and i came back from it stronger and i
feel like
i am even though i've continued to take
psychedelics ever since on occasion
i've never gone to that place again
and i'm kind of grateful for that
you know and i also feel that i'm
basically a fairly stable person
let me ask a couple of follow-up
questions because what there are a few
things that
struck me in the book in describing this
and people should pick up the book and
and read
all of it including this chronicle only
the kindle version is available as you
know
which is perfect for me because i can't
take it
no more hard to come by so i can take
notes and then export my notes which is
my favorite thing in the world to do
so i have you know i have my 189
highlights and then i went through and i
added three asterisks
to the things i wanted to follow up on
that's a six page document so i'm
fully nerded out when it comes to my
digestion of this book
and that please fill in the details or
fact check me on this but one of the
things that struck me and this also
seems to be a pattern across people who
and i don't want to characterize your
experience this way but those people who
might come unmoored and stay
adrift for longer periods of time is
there was a real density
of consumption of philosophy mushrooms
when you're there and my understanding
is you guys had very little
in terms of food maybe some some instant
noodles
and rice and you had this just
almost ridiculous abundance of
mushrooms due to these cebu cattle who
were
who were down there and so you just you
started spicing up meals
and so on going in psychedelic mushrooms
uh so you had just a not only a high
dose experience and there's a lot more
to it of course but
you had a really high density of
continuous
consumption is that accurate is that
fair to say
yes yes yes and so we never
really in this process we never really
did give ourselves a chance to
get back to baseline as you will and
look at well what's
what's going on here now that we're
unstoned we were never on stone
most of what happened with the
experiment in lecturera when we actually
performed the experimented lecturer was
post mushroom we weren't eating them
anymore oh that's right that was about
two weeks
there were plenty of them in our system
yeah
so and then of course on the night that
we that we didn't experience
we ate them but yeah mushrooms are
tricky
mushrooms are not necessarily to
be trusted in a certain way because they
can lead you
into these delusional spaces
and as a planned teacher well they're
not plants but you know as a psychedelic
teacher
they're somewhat less trustworthy than
ayahuasca i feel
like you know i mean you can get into
these delusional spaces and
it's something to be careful of yeah
certainly not to be trifled
with in a sense that you you should i
think it's a good idea to respect
much from you none of these things
should be
to follow up on that you know you
mentioned letting things play out and
how that was beneficial
to you and your reintegration
and perhaps if you had been subjected at
that point
to a psychiatric intervention that that
could have
been problematic for you you know this
presents
a dicey situation i suppose for people
who might experience things in the sense
that
as a counterweight to that i know one
person for instance who
who went to peru did a
traditional dieta where he was consuming
something called chiriksanango
and ayahuasca on alternating days
and he did this for quite a long period
of time and chirixed
in a number of cases now people who've
had psychotic breaks
after sort of continuous administration
not to say it's bad
i just think that they're this is this
is a an observed
kind of phenomenon and his
family had to go down to south america
he thought he was god
and convinced him that if he were god
the gift he could give would be getting
on this thing that was
made up in his mind called an airplane
and coming back to the united states
but i suppose there is there's a
plausible argument to be made that he
would have been
sort of among the lost and maybe would
not have come out by himself
so how do you think about when it is
appropriate
and again we're not giving medical
advice everybody needs to talk to their
medical professionals but would there
not be times when a psychiatric
intervention would be called for
how do you think about that there would
definitely be times
when a psychiatric intervention i'm not
saying
that every time for me the fact that the
experience did play itself out what was
allowed to play out was this process of
integration
and integration is really important as
you know
so psychedelic experience and this
process of
getting back to some kind of baseline
but with that changed perspective with
the benefit of having
had this experience and changing that
perspective and so on
but sometimes i mean this is why
sentence setting is so
important and when you take it in a
inappropriate sense setting then
there's the potential to come up against
what we call the real world you know
society and its conventions
and its expectations i mean for example
i can share with you
the sun of a very good friend of mine in
minnesota
at about age 18 went with his
i don't know what his previous
psychedelic experience had been
not not great but a few low-level
mushroom experiences and so on but he
decided with some of his friends to
take a trip to new york city just like
small
town boys in the big city you know and
just having a great time
they took a lot of mushrooms and he sort
of
descended into this delusional world
his friends said well we're going back
to minnesota
and he said well i'm staying here
what are you going to do live on the
streets yes and he had this whole thing
well it didn't take very long for him to
come up against new york's finest
as you might say because he was acting
pretty strange
and he he got into a tussle with the
cops
and punched one in the face oh
that was a big mistake next thing you
know he was
in jail and being transferred to what is
the huge psychiatric hospital there
bedlam or something uh bedlam bellevue
maybe
bellevue bellevue the only reason
that he was able to
resolve it in some ways was that at this
point i was getting involved i was
actually in brazil
as an ayahuasca retreat when all this
was going on but my friend called me and
said
this has happened is there anybody in
new york
a psychiatrist that could help him and
as it turned out i said well yeah as a
matter of fact
steve ross might be able to help him and
i called steve this was all done
by skype there was you know when i
called stephen i explained the situation
and he said well as it turns out i have
admission privileges of bellevue
which i had no idea that he did but he
went over there
and was able to intervene on this young
man's behalf
and get him out of there but the guy
never did recover
he went back he was on psychiatric meds
and he was fairly functional when he
was doing that but he hated being on
psychiatric meds
and it just it was a tragedy
in many ways he never fully recovered
how old was he at this time he was about
18 or 19. did he have a family history
of schizophrenia or anything like that
potentially yes there was schizophrenia
in his family
it was a very strange family situation
i mean his mother was a devout
evangelical
christian and his father was uh
like a psychedelic cowboy he grew his
mushrooms in the basement and
brewed his own ayahuasca and so on and
so it was a weird family situation and
it was very bad i i don't want to
disclose too much but
of course of course i mean it's very
it's very sad it was a very sad outcome
so this is a case of
it's hard to predict but apparently he
had this family
history of schizophrenia and he was and
the mushrooms triggered this
so uh this is why you have to
approach it from an informed place
and hopefully with a practitioner
whether a therapist or a shaman or
whatever
who can hold that space and
modulate the outcome to take it on the
streets of new york
probably not a good idea you know
especially if you're not from
new york i don't know yeah for sure i
mean it
it also just brings to mind okay maybe
it should be the four s's right you have
screening
set setting and then support like you
have a safety
you have a safety net in place before
you get on the trapeze
that's right somebody who's actually
supervising
this was just approached by these young
men
in a very recreational way and they were
out to have a good time and
uh it was not good yeah powerful
compounds and
i mean this applies sort of across the
entire pharmacopoeia right i mean ssris
also can produce
suicidal ideation in all sorts of states
so you just really
it's a really good idea to have
professional
assistance and supervision with these
things
yeah well let's talk about the mckenna
academy of natural philosophy
because you bring so many
different perspectives and lenses
and also toolkits to bear on these
discussions
i would just love to hear about this
new non-profit and why you started it
the new nonprofit the mckenna academy of
natural philosophy which is
www.mckenna.academy
academy is the suffix of of the website
and i wanted to create a originally the
idea that
was that we would start this academy and
that we would have
a physical place in south america where
we could do
retreats which we had been doing all
along
and then conferences and different types
of educational
activities to explore natural philosophy
and a lot of it was the ideas that would
be a modern mystery school
modeled after ellucis or not modeled
after it but in that
spirit a place where people could come
together and share ideas
and marvel at the cosmos and marvel at
existence and do what natural
philosophers do
natural philosophy being the precursor
of science what science
used to be before it became so
quantitative
and reductionist natural philosophy
is the root of science and
it differs from science in that admits
that
there are other ways of knowing rather
than the reductionist way of knowing
that's valuable but that's not the whole
trick this is the uh
limitation of science science can
understand
segments of reality but small in small
pieces
but it doesn't fit the whole picture
together too well
so the academy is basically i guess the
modern analog
it would be something like esselm a
place
where ideas and brilliant minds can come
together
and create dialogues and of course kovit
changed our business model radically
because we couldn't do these conferences
and so on so we've had to pivot
and go online and that's what we're
doing now
just trying to create an online presence
and continue our work it's partly
educational it's partly research
we've got a project going on down in
peru right now
we're making a documentary about the
current state
of traditional medicine in the amazon
around the quitos and a lot of it is
about
this botanist that i've worked with for
40 years there who's the
curator of the herbarium at the
university
in iquitos and he's one of these people
about which it said when a medicine man
dies it's as though a library has burned
down
well he's not a medicine man in the
sense that he's not a healer but he has
tremendous knowledge of the amazonian
flora
and the medicine properties of these
plants
and he knows many many healers in the
community
so we're trying to document his
knowledge
because even though he's a scientist he
doesn't write things down so we're
trying to
through videography make a documentary
about what he knows
and then hopefully that will attract
funding we have big plans for this
project
we call it the knowledge preservation
project
the first aspect of it is to make a
short
relatively short documentary about this
gentleman whose name is juan ruiz
and then to develop over the long term
what we want to do is
work with the herbarium there and
digitize the herbarium and try to
make it into a world-class resource for
plant research of all kinds that would
be
centered at the university so this is
all described in our
website and that's probably our biggest
project right now for which we're
seeking support
support and so people can find that
mckenna dot academy i encourage
everybody to check it out
there are five key departments tell me
if this requires updating but you have
therapeutics
education retreats r d and media is that
still
an accurate reflection or has that been
modified that's an accurate reflection
but then
some of those things are kind of dormant
at the moment like the retreats
due to covid due to colvin i mean
eventually we want to get back to that
media obviously is an even bigger part
of it because
the internet is our teaching platform
now
therapeutics again not so much because
they're usually associated with to
retreat
but education for sure and r d
this project that we're doing with this
with this gentleman at
unapp the university there is in the
category of r
d and the mckenna academy is
is a public charity is that right that
in the sense that it's tax-exempt as a
501 c
it is it's a 501 c 3 tax-exempt
organization
chartered in the united states even
though i don't live in the united states
anymore
i live close enough i live in canada now
but the uh the academy is uh
incorporated in california as a 501c3
and who is involved with the academy
besides yourself are there any
particular
people who are acting as as advisors
or research collaborators
oh definitely yeah we have a number of
people that are
associated with it the woman who is the
executive director
christina chia lives in peru
and i've worked with her previously on
organizing retreats
so she continues to work with me we have
very good people
on our board one gentleman with lots of
experience in the financial industry
another
woman is a corporate lawyer
so we have that expertise and then we
have
just a fantastic bunch of advisors
one of whom is alexandre tanu who
you know very well and way davis
his advisor paul stamets is an advisor
so we have a number of high-profile
people yeah have a strong
strong roster yeah definitely what types
of projects would be on the short list
of things that you would like
to engage with and explore
assuming that you have the resources to
do so well a couple of things
are on the plate so we've got this kind
of long-term
project this knowledge preservation
project which we're
beginning to brand it as biognosis
and that is the focus right now is on
the documentation part
but then the next phase which will take
much longer and cost a lot more money
is to focus on the herbarium there of
which juan ruiz is the curator
of this herbarium so that's a long-term
project that we want to do
in the shorter term we're working on
developing an ethnobotany course
in collaboration with the organization
for
tropical studies in costa rica
and we're going to be offering that
course this fall
and one of the people that is working on
that
is a guy named michael coe who is an
ethnobotanist and i was on his committee
he got his degree
at the university of hawaii and he
studied cultural keystone species
in the amazon around pukulpa which is
basically ayahuasca he is going to be
the
main instructor in this course which
will be online
and then we're planning to do a virtual
symposium
probably in august on the stone date
theory
and we're going to do that because one
of terence's books the food of the gods
is being reprinted again i'm actually
doing a
online event with michael pollan and the
publisher
we're doing a essentially a podcast
together
but then we're going to do a one-day
symposium on the stone tape theory and
have some
interesting speakers i wrote a new
forward for it
which i'll be happy to share with you
and
we're going to have this symposium
because we're going to revisit this
whole
idea which actually based on
new discoveries is more plausible than
it was
when terence first proposed it and
that's what my forward is about in part
is that we didn't know about the way
that these
psychedelics can create these
hyperconnected
neural architectures and neurogenesis
and
enhancing the connectivity in the
neocortex and that sort of thing
and that was not known at the time
terence wrote the book
what was also not known was anything
about epigenetics
and epigenetics provides an evolutionary
mechanism by which
these changes in
neural architecture could be propagated
through generations so if you look at
the
environment that we now know from
paleoclimatic data and that sort of
thing northern africa was a
wet place a couple of million years ago
and there was seasonal rainfall there
were cattle there
there were the ancestors of the modern
cattle and there were hominins
so the the three variables
in this environment did exist what was
the long-term
impact of that well you know the the
food of the gods it basically
led to the origin of consciousness and
the imagination
yeah i read a draft of your
intro or maybe the final version i don't
know but it's really a great
exploration review of more recent
findings but also great exploration of
language images imagination
consciousness
and then also the data to support this
overlap
of hominids with ungulates
and coprophilic mushrooms
it seems almost inevitable that our
ancestors would have been munching on
these
and found them very
very interesting and compelling on a lot
of things
so so so yeah i i just think it's worth
looking at this in the light of some new
discoveries
i mean you know these things can never
be proven which
actually makes them more fun because
then you can make these
wild claims and nobody can disprove them
either
you know so that's where we're at with
them
but i think knowing what we know about
neuroplasticity was the word i was
looking for
that psychedelics foster neuroplasticity
epigenetics provides a
mechanism for inheritance and so i think
that changes the
speculation from plausible to maybe
more than likely yeah this stuff is
endlessly fascinating to me and
i want to return for a second to the
mckenna academy of natural philosophy
because you
you mentioned something that i just want
to underscore
and that is that to do these things that
is
to further the knowledge preservation
project biognosis
the ethnobonding course and many other
things you are
currently looking for support if you
don't mind
saying if you can is there a specific
number that you have determined will
allow you to pursue
these projects with the resources
required to really
gain some degree of traction with with
them
yes i mean we have we have a rough idea
we're undertaking a capital campaign
now fundraising campaign people should
feel free to visit the website and
donate if it grabs you but we're looking
to
raise about 600 000
by the end of the year and this is to
support various
projects like this and then the
herbarium
digitization project which is much more
ambitious
and much more expensive and it's going
to stretch over a couple of years
what we're dealing with is essentially
an herbarium which is a
gem a scientific gym but it's in a
third world developing country
university
so there are a lot of deficiencies for
example
at this herbarium there's like a hundred
thousand specimens but at least
half of them aren't even mounted so
we want to get enough funds to
complete the herbarium essentially and
then link it into various online
database
resources for natural products
pharmacology
genomics and so on just create an open
access
resource for anyone with an interest in
amazonian flora
you know it doesn't have to be medicinal
or psychedelic
or whatever the interest and that's
probably going to be a two to
three year project that'll cost
somewhere north of a million dollars
but it will be well worthwhile it's just
again i'm a big believer in
collections and collecting knowledge
that's the thing
knowledge collections are important and
like every
plant that you can attach a piece of
information to
enhances the value of the plant you know
and provides a reason
not to drive it into extinction
important yeah once they're gone they're
gone you've mentioned a phrase
in a number of other interviews i
listened to that i'd love for you to
define because i don't know the phrase
and i would like to the importance of
voucher specimens i think that was the
wording
is that is that the right word what is a
voucher specimen
voucher specimen this is what schulte
used to rave about all the time
he would go on about well they did all
this chemical work on say
banisteriopsis for example and there is
a whole
history of chemical investigations
going back to the late 19th century
people looking into the
alkaloids the composition of
banisteriopsis
voucher specimen is simply a herbarium
specimen that you
make and if you're collecting plants and
you're dragging them
back into the lab to tear them apart
chemically and see what's in there
you have to be able to reference a
reference specimen essentially
so keep one that you don't tear apart in
other words collect
pieces of the plant make an herbarium
specimen
of the plant make several in different
herbaria around the world
but at least the herbarium of the host
country
and then you can always go back to that
because
taxonomists love to
question each other and so if you have a
reference specimen you can always go
back and look at the actual collection
somebody said well this is
banisteriopsis
copy you know that mckenna collected in
1981. but five years later some other
botanist may come through there and say
well that wasn't banisteriopsis copy
that was venesteriopsis logiolatin
you know and these people are fools they
didn't know what they were doing
this is what taxonomists do all the time
you know they fight with each other
but the point is that the chemical
investigations
are documented by an herbarium specimen
that you can always go back and check
and now of course they
use dna profiling and this this sort of
thing
just another tool in the arsenal kind of
but
if you look at the chemical history
of ayahuasca if you look at who did what
when they were sorting out
what the alkaloids were the first
four or five investigators i can send
you a keynote about this
which you can look at at your leisure
but the first four or five groups of
investigators they didn't take vouchers
so their work is not worthless
but in some ways degraded because they
are not
vouchers to document what they actually
worked on
that's the thing with voucher specimens
and i mean just to put some more
connective tissue around let's just say
the
the amazon and the flora
of the amazon how many species would you
say
we we currently estimate plant species
to exist
in the amazon in the amazon yeah
about 80 to 90 000 and how how many have
we
and this is maybe a loaded word but
properly studied and
examined in any way what percentage
around 10
if that of course worldwide they're
probably
they're always revising the number but
the total number of plant
species higher plant species in the
world is around
240 240 to 260
000. and i mean it's just such a
wealth of biological
not just knowledge but practicality i
mean you have
such potential medicinal application
well there's there's great discovery
great potential for drug discovery
because we have only looked at about 10
percent
and those are the the number that
you know we maybe took a superficial
look at
the number that have actually been
thoroughly investigated
is closer to one percent so there's
tremendous
potential to find new compounds in fact
that's another
project that the mckenna academy is
working on
or collaborating with a group called
woven science
a group of entrepreneurs and
and scientists and other types
and we're in process of developing a
bioprospecting
platform that will be affiliated with
the university in in aquitos
and then you get into basically a search
for new molecules
screen them against a whole variety of
possible targets
so this is another long-term project
that will probably run
into the millions if it's properly done
the mckenna academy is kind of
peripheral to it where
we're involved but we're not you know
we're non-profits so we don't have to
make
profits but it's going to be a very
interesting
project and it goes into these ethical
areas about
who owns this knowledge biopiracy
yeah biopiracy so we have to be very
sensitive to all those issues so that we
can say
you know we're bioprospectors
not bile pirates we want to share the
the wealth if there's any return
on the investment we're committed to
having indigenous people
have a big stake in that have a place at
the table
and a big say in how this goes forward
because really they've been the stewards
of this knowledge for
millennia really and it's always been
the case that
big pharma big science comes in they
take what they want they say thanks very
much see you later
develop billion dollar drugs off these
things and that's not right
the indigenous people should get some
recognition for being the stewards of
this knowledge that's the whole thing
this is what's in danger as the habitats
are impacted
the community structures are impacted
and the traditional knowledge and one of
the first things to go
is the knowledge of plants well dennis
there are a million things
that i could ask you i i didn't even get
through ten percent
of the questions yeah yeah so we have we
have space for many more
conversations yeah uh i want to say a
few things one is
that for those people listening will
also want to
sort of extend their exploration of
these topics i think mark plotkin has
also done
a lot of great work with the amazon
conservation team
in his thinking about enabling and
empowering those groups
to participate in in prospecting
and the preservation of of knowledge
he's done
he and his and his wife and other people
in the organization have done really
great work
and i know you guys are friends and go
back really really really really far
and i also wanted to ask so just to just
to confirm for people listening
donations to the mckenna academy of
natural philosophy are tax deductibles
since they are
donations to 501c3 so i will the target
of 600k
i will commit here to kicking that off
with 50k of my own usd
and i want to encourage people listening
to consider
doing the same because at 50k pop that
would be 12 people
it could be done very easily this is a
early stage
bet albeit in a non-profit so i don't
expect of course i can't get any returns
from this in a financial way but i i
view you as a pioneer who also has
a high degree of biochemical and
sort of ethnobotanical fluency who can
participate and reconcile and critically
examine multiple
spheres and you have a history of
producing
really fascinating and i think important
work
and i definitely encourage people to
also grab the
ethnopharmacologic search for
psychoactive drugs they're in a boxed
set if you just search dennis mckenna on
amazon it pops right
up and you can purchase it on amazon
prime it's a beautiful
collection it will give you a taste of
some of what
dennis has curated and certainly you can
find his writing everywhere else but i
will commit to 50k
i encourage people to uh you know this
is not investment advice it's a
non-profit but
i i really view this as
as worthwhile and you're coming into
this also as
someone who has proven a decades-long
dedication
to examining and studying
various facets of psychedelics and
beyond not just
limited to that much like i think
schulte's was also
very very well versed in orchids and
other things one of the world's experts
on
orchids that's right yeah roland
griffiths also a lot of people don't
realize even though he's known for the
psychedelic work with
psilocybin at hopkins one of the
foremost
experts in caffeine and caffeine
metabolism and so you
you have such a broad spectrum of
expertise
i feel like this is worth supporting so
i commit
to 50k and i encourage people to take a
close look
that's incredibly generous of you tim
thank you
thank you for that and and thank you for
encouraging your listeners to
contribute if we get a few more
donations in that range we won't have to
do a fundraising campaign because
our goals will be pretty much met and
yeah we want to be responsible stewards
of these funds
you know and in that regard we're
also open to people who
they may want to support us financially
but we want more than just finances we
want advice
we want wise people we are creating a
a we call it the symbiotic circle but a
circle of
advisors with connections to other
supporters but also ideas like
people like yourself for example i don't
know if you're
interested in being joining our
symbiotic circle but
uh you're certainly welcome to well
thank you i like the sound
i like the sound of it symbiotic circle
sounds like a good information about
all this stuff i i don't know how much
time you have to go through all this
stuff but i'm gonna send you
the one thing in the world that i seem
to have time for is this kind of stuff
okay well i'll send you more details
about
that that capital campaign and some of
the other projects that we have
and yeah this has just been amazing we
killed uh two and a half hours
yeah it was easy yes it was easy to do
and uh we have plenty i have enough
questions we could we could do a round
two
in short order be extremely easy to do i
would encourage people to check out
mckenna dot
academy i have a few thoughts on things
that could be added to the website that
might be helpful for listeners so we'll
chat about that separately
i think it'd be easy to do also but
check out mckenna dot academy
certainly you can find dennis on social
where are you most
active if you're active at all dennis on
social media
well i have people handling most of the
social media for the academy
so i'm not on there i'm on facebook and
twitter
but not not much you know
yeah well that's that's why you get more
done yeah well i
wouldn't say that but it helps it helps
but
i would love to have more conversations
with you
tim online and offline yeah
enjoy that this has just been uh this
has just been incredible
you're a fantastic interviewer i'm sure
i'm not the first to told you that
thank you and you're informed
you really do your homework so that's
that's a huge
thing i think it could have been gone
better right
yeah we could talk all afternoon
[Laughter]
easily and i i'm only you know 30 40
percent of the way
through volume two of uh espd and
this is one of those fields i'm sure
it's true with a lot of fields where
the deeper you go the more fascinating
and the stranger it all becomes and
you know it's and and you spoke to at
the very very
well maybe it was in the beginning maybe
it was in the middle about
some fears around and this was related
to
some of these syncretic churches of
science removing
the mystery or the wonder and it makes
me think
of surely you must be joking mr fineman
by richard feynman famed physicist
who later in life developed a deep
friendship with
a painter and the painter had the same
concern
about richard through his scientific
lens
removing the wonder of say the beauty of
a flower
and richard's perspective was actually
you've got it completely backwards
because i have the aesthetic
appreciation
i am acutely aware of how much i don't
know and
i can also be dazzled by the
scientific findings when you go down to
the microscopic level and look at this
beautiful thing in front of us
and i'm paraphrasing of course but i
find it so reassuring
in your representation of these multiple
facets that
these are not mutually exclusive silos
even though there's so much goddamn
infighting in the psychedelic space it's
kind of
comically tragic we're humans
you know that's what we do but i
am totally on the same page with you
about this
to my mind science properly
pursued only deepens the mystery
yeah that's the thing it doesn't take
the mystery away it shows you
how mystery exists profoundly
at every level that's the whole idea of
the mckenna academy being a mystery
school
the mystery is the mystery of existence
which is
which is bottomless it's endless and
science is
one of those tools we have not to take
the mystery away but to make us
appreciate
what the mystery is and i'm thinking of
something but i had a couple of
exchanges they said tim's going to ask
you
what would you put on a billboard you
know
and well we didn't get to that but i was
thinking about that what i would put on
the billboard is what i
get from ayahuasca and other
psychedelics which is
remember how little you know
remember how little you know and science
often forgets how little it knows
yeah so it can be kind of arrogant at
times
but you can't be a true scientist
without being a mystic
i think you know i mean that's the thing
the deeper you probe
the more complex the more beautiful
the more intelligent it all seems yeah
and this is why i think we have to
appreciate science but understand it's
not the whole
story it's not the end of the story just
a useful tool
yeah we're all holding different parts
of the elephant like that parable
yeah and dennis this has been wonderful
i will follow up on the donation which
for clarity i'll make through my
foundation
which is explicitly for this type of
thing could not be more excited
is there anything else you would like to
mention
to listeners any closing comments
anything like that
anything you'd like to direct their
attention to before
we wrap up for this round one no i think
we've covered it pretty well
i would say look at the website we have
resources there we have events which
have been done in the past that you can
still register
they're all recorded think of it as a
place for
resources and so on but also get in
touch
we want to be open we want people to
bring their talent and their their
wisdom
and everything else to the table and
their money but that's not necessarily
that's not necessarily the the most
valuable thing money is just the grease
that lets the thing
run yeah so there is that but
we're we're trying to bring together
brilliant people
and propagate this worldview this idea
that we're out of sync with nature
essentially and that psychedelics is
one way to help us realize that and help
us get realigned with nature because
that's the
big challenge that we face right now and
you know and then that could spin off
into
another three hours of discussion we
won't go into
it yeah yeah for sure and uh for those
people who want
maybe a cliffhanger or a teaser i wanted
to focus on a lot of the science and the
biographical stuff in this conversation
but we we didn't even get into some of
the really strange and weird stuff which
we might next time that's another that's
another one yeah
yeah so i'll leave that as a teaser for
around two well thank you so much dennis
this has been wonderful
and so much fun for me i've been really
looking forward to this and
have done so much reading and i can't
wait to do more
i'm looking forward to it and to
everybody listening
as always we will have links to
everything in the show notes that we've
discussed
of course we mentioned mckenna dot
academy that is
sort of the beacon the the main call to
action here
please check it out and until next time
be safe and thanks for tuning in
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday do
you want to get
a short email from me would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
friday
that provides a little more soul of fun
before the weekend and
five bullet friday is a very short email
where i share the coolest things
i've found or that i've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that i've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up in
the
the world of the esoteric as i do it
could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short it's just
a little tiny bite of goodness before
you head off
for the weekend so if you want to
receive that check it out
just go to four hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by all
form if you've been listening to this
podcast for a while you've probably
heard me talk about helix
sleep and their mattresses which i've
been using since 2017. i have two of
them
upstairs from where i'm sitting at this
moment and now helix has gone beyond the
bedroom and started making
sofas they just launched a new company
called all form a-l-l-f-o-r-m and
they're making premium
customizable sofas and chairs shipped
right to your door at a fraction of the
cost of traditional stores
so i'm sitting in my living room right
now and it's entirely all form
furniture i've got two chairs i've got
an ottoman and i have an
l sectional couch and i'll come back to
that
you can pick your fabric they're all
spill stain and scratch resistant the
soap
color the color of the legs the sort of
size the shape to make sure it's perfect
for you and your home
also all form arrives in just three to
seven days and you can assemble it all
yourself in a few minutes no tools
needed i was quite astonished by how
modular
and easy these things fit together kind
of like lego pieces they've got arm
chairs love seats all the way up to an
eight seat
sectional so there's something for
everyone you can also start small and
kind of build on top of it if you want
to get a smaller couch and then build
out on it which is actually in a way
what i did because i can turn
my l-sectional couch into a normal
straight couch and then with a separate
ottoman
in a matter of about 60 seconds it's
pretty rad so
i mentioned i have all these different
things in this room i use the natural
leg finish which is their lightest color
and i dig it i mean i've been using
these things hours and hours and hours
every single day so i am using
what i am sharing with you guys and if
getting a sofa without trying it in
store sounds risky
you don't need to worry all form sofas
are delivered directly to your home with
fast free shipping and you get 100 days
to decide if you want to keep it
that's more than three months and if you
don't love it they'll pick it up for
free and give you a full refund
your sofa frame also has a forever
warranty that's literally
forever so check it out take a look
they've got all sorts of cool stuff
to choose from i was skeptical and it
actually worked it worked much better
than i could have
imagined and i'm very very happy so to
find your perfect sofa check out
allform.com
tim that's a-l-l-f-o-r
tim all form is offering 20 off all
orders to you my dear listeners at
allform.com
tim make sure to use the code tim at
checkout
that's allforum.com tim and use code tim
at checkout this episode is brought to
you by
tonal t-o-n-a-l get ready for the
smartest home gym you've ever
seen that's a men's health headline
about tonal folks and that gives you the
gist
if you're wondering about the smart part
tonal's homepage also features a quote
from the new york times
quote the machine knew my strength
better than i did
and put more on that in just a minute by
eliminating traditional metal weights
tonal can deliver 200 pounds of
resistance in a device smaller than a
flat screen tv
total mounts on your wall with no floor
space required
i've had a tonal unit now for six to 12
months
which i got after a number of very close
friends who recommended tonal
and it allows me to do things i would
normally need a much
larger gym for like cable chop and lift
or rotational exercises things i wrote
about
in the four hour body and it allows me
to do these things that are nearly
impossible otherwise like eccentric
loading which i'll mention later
tonal is precision engineered and
designed to be the world's most advanced
strength studio and personal trainer
it uses breakthrough technology like
adaptive digital weights and ai learning
together with the best experts in
resistance training so you get stronger
faster so what are these adaptive
digital weights tonal's patented digital
weight system
makes thousands of calculations a second
to deliver you a smooth
weight lifting experience using advanced
electronic motor technology
total lets you adjust the weight in one
pound increments something that was
never possible with traditional
dumbbells
easy to dial weights up and down with
the touch of a button right in the grip
itself it's pretty cool tonal also has
built-in dynamic weight modes like
chains eccentric that's
e-c-c-e-n-t-r-i-c
and their patent-pending smart flex
technology so you can experiment with
more ways to get stronger
faster without the hassle of extra
equipment like chains
and bands and it once again fits
on the wall like flat screen tv so you
can make
the best use out of the smallest
footprint in
your home or garage wherever you end up
putting it so try tonal
t-o-n-a-l the world's smartest home gym
for 30 days in your home and if you
don't love it
you can return it for a full refund
visit www.tonal.com
and for a limited time get 100 off of
the smart accessories when you use promo
code
tim 100 at checkout that's www.tonal.com
promo code tim 100 be
your strongest